now speaking of media bias you may you
may recall that Pamela and I hosted a
rally in June on this
spot and many of you were here and the
media coverage was all about an Arabic
speaking man who was supposedly roughed
up by the crowd
and that showed that we were all racist
anti-muslim islamophobic bigots well
he's our next
speaker Joseph nasrala
came from
California to support this cause and to
stand against this mosque in June and he
is here again today he is a Coptic
Christian human rights activist from
Egypt and the founder of the way TV a
Christian satellite TV station and so
please welcome Joseph nasrala
God Bless
America God Bless
America wake up America
wake up all the states of
America we love you we love you I came
from
Egypt Egypt was Coptic was
Christians
from 100
1,400 years Islamic conquer our country
with their lies you know they're written
in the Holy it's not holy it's written
in the
Quran it's written in the Quran that the
war is
deceiving they can lie just to build
this mosque here on my dead
body on my dead
body you know why because I escape from
Egypt for a freedom here where I can go
you need me to go to the moon now to
have a a land on the Moon so you know
what the Muslims said we are the
intelligent people who is the first one
land on the moon do you think this is a
true it's not a true they are
lying I'm not against the Muslims Islam
is the big ideology
here they
coming they using tea they using
deceiving they lie for the pastor for
they lie for pamila Giller and Robert
Spencer they lying lying lying lying I
hate lying you come here for
Freedom I'm sorry to show you my
picture this is one of our dear friends
in
Egypt one of
eight eight of them in the Christmas
night in the name of
Islam they said Allah
abbar and they kill
them in front of the
church 3,000 person burned here in the
same area they they need to build a
mosque and can you imagine that can you
imagine the rale did you see the rale
it's kind of mess it's kind of
mess donations donations
donations you know the truth $100
million comes to Sheikh
fael I know the truth because I'm from
Egypt I know the truth because our
country after
1400 years they came and Conquer our
country the same way they need to
conquer
America you know what I need to see I
need to say something and I will finish
I promise five
minutes in 10 years if this mosque buil
built here if they built this mosque
here in 10 years believe me in 10 years
using TAA using islamized of this
country America you cannot stop them you
cannot stop the Islam at this time it
going to be too late that's why I'm
saying to you now I'm coming all the way
from California and the in behalf of all
the cus Egyptians and the Christians and
all every even the human rights I'm
saying to you wake up
America wake up
America you are in the TV right now you
are on the TV right now you are on the
TV right now 2 million chrisan hearing
your voice hearing your voice right now
wake up America you don't need to be
like this picture you don't need to be
stop islamization of America we love you
thank you